Now, we've been discussing
steady uniform precession,
which is the simplest possible
case of a phenomenon that
can be much more complicated.
As an example and the
case we've been discussing
so far where we release a
gyroscope from rest when it's
horizontal, very
careful measurements
would show that the
initial motion isn't
just steady precession but
has some additional motion
superimposed on it.
The spin axis sort
of bounces or nods
up and down as it precesses.
However, friction
at the pivot point
causes the amplitude
of the nodding
to rapidly decay until it
settles into steady precession.
This nodding motion
is called nutation.
In our example, it
decays so quickly
that we don't even notice it.
But if you had a perfectly
frictionless pivot point,
it would be a more
noticeable effect.
And it would persist
for much longer.
Now, there's an
interesting point
about our horizontal gyroscope
that I'd like to point out.
So here is my rod of length d.
This is my point s.
Here's my wheel that's rotating
with some angular velocity.
And again, there's
the r hat direction.
That's the direction that little
omega vector's pointing in.
That's the k hat direction.
And that's the
theta hat direction.
Now, before I release it,
before I release the gyroscope
from rest, the angular
momentum vector
points in the r hat direction,
as drawn at this instant.
When I release it
from rest, there
is a torque acting
in the theta hat
direction that causes
the angular momentum
vector to rotate.
And we've seen this
in some detail.
But there's something
else to keep
in mind, which is that now
when the system is precessing,
that means that the center
of mass of the wheel
is orbiting around the
z-axis, the vertical axis,
through this pivot point.
So you can think of that as a
point mass with the full mass
of the gyroscope moving in
a circular path around point
s with a radius d.
That implies that there must be
a component of angular momentum
pointing in the k hat
direction, pointing along
the z-axis, corresponding
to the translational motion
of the center of mass, the
circular translational motion
of the center of mass, of the
gyroscope around the z-axis.
But where did that k
component come from?
There was no initial z component
of the angular momentum.
We said that initially the
angular momentum just pointed
in the r hat direction.
And there's no torque
in the k hat direction.
The only torque is in
the theta hat direction.
So how do we end up with some
angular momentum pointing
in the k hat direction?
This seems to violate
the conservation
of angular momentum.
The solution to this puzzle is
that, in fact, the gyroscope
doesn't remain precisely
horizontal when I release it.
Instead, it dips by
a very small angle.
So that's the horizontal.
After I release
it, the gyroscope's
actually dipped downward
by a small amount.
I've exaggerated it
considerably in this drawing.
We'll call that
angle delta theta.
That small dip gives the
small negative component
of the spin angular
momentum that's
able to balance
the plus z angular
momentum due to the
motion center of mass.
Now, because the spin
angular momentum vector
has such a large magnitude--
that's my spin angular
momentum vector--
only a small angle
is necessary in order
to get enough of a
negative Lz component
to balance out the
Lz corresponding
to the center of mass motion.
OK?
But what we see is that
although gyroscopes
seem like a remarkable
system, they're not magic.
And, in fact, angular
momentum is conserved.
The larger little
omega is, the faster
the spin angular velocity is.
And, therefore, the
larger the vector L
is, the smaller that angle
is and the less of a dip
that you get.
So now we can write the
exact angular momentum
for the gyroscope.
This is my distance d.
This is my pivot point s.
My spin angular velocity
looks like that.
Here is the r hat direction, the
k hat direction, and the theta
hat direction into the screen.
And we're orbiting--
the precession is around
the z-axis with an angular
speed capital omega.
Now, recall that
the total angular
momentum with respect to point
s can be written in two parts.
There's the angular momentum
due to the translational motion
of the center of mass.
And we know the
center of mass is just
orbiting around the z-axis.
So I'll call that, in fact,
the orbital angular momentum.
So this is due to
the translation
of the center of mass
with respect to point s.
And then the second term is
due to the rotational angular
momentum, or spin
angular momentum,
relative to the center of mass.
So this is due to rotation
about the center of mass.
So again, the general angular
momentum of a rigid body
is equal to the center of
mass translational angular
momentum plus the angular
momentum due to rotation,
a pure rotation, about
the center of mass.
So let's write each
of these terms.
The orbital angular
momentum, that
is the translational angular
momentum of the center of mass,
is just due to the motion
of the center of mass
of the gyroscope, which is
at radius d with respect
to point s, moving in a circle
with angular speed capital
omega.
So that's equal to the
mass times the center
of mass velocity times
the radius of the circle.
And that angular momentum
is in the k hat direction.
But the center of
mass velocity is
just equal to-- since
it's a circular motion--
is just equal to the
radius of the circle,
d, times the angular speed
of the circular motion
of the center of mass,
which is capital omega.
So I can write this
as m capital omega d
squared in the k hat direction.
So that's the angular momentum
due to the translational motion
of the center of
mass around point s,
what I'm calling the
orbital angular momentum.
Now, the spin angular
momentum, we've
been talking about
the rapid spin
of the wheel around its axis.
So that's given by
the moment of inertia
about that axis times the
spin angular velocity.
And that's pointing in
the r hat direction.
But there's a subtlety here.
It turns out that is
not the only rotation
about the center of mass that
this wheel is undergoing.
And actually because of that,
I'm going to call this I1.
And let me just
draw a picture here.
So for my disk rotating
around this axis,
the relevant moment of
inertia is what I'll call I1.
And for a disk, we know that
would be 1/2 m r squared.
The other rotation
is a subtle one.
Notice in this
drawing, suppose I
were to draw a dot on the
outside face of the wheel.
When this wheel precessed
around 180 degrees
to the other side,
that dot on the outside
would be facing in the
minus r hat direction now
or would be pointing to the
left rather than to the right.
And what that means is
that this disk has actually
rotated about its diameter.
So this disk has rotated
around a diameter like this.
And that rotation is at the
slower angular speed capital
omega.
And it takes one full orbit for
it to rotate entirely around.
If that rotation
weren't happening--
this wouldn't make
sense physically the way
I have this set up.
But as an object, if that
rotation weren't happening,
what that would mean is that
this face with a dot on it
would always be pointing to the
right as the disk moved around.
If it had an independent pivot
point right at the center,
it would be physically
possible for it to do that.
That's not what's
happening in this case.
In this case, this face is
always pointing outward,
radially away from
the pivot point.
And that results in a
rotation around this diameter.
Now, it turns out that moment
of inertia, which I'll call I2,
happens to be half the moment
of inertia for this axis.
So in this case, it's
one 1/4 m r squared.
So that is another
kind of rotation
that's happening about
the center of mass.
And so there's an additional
angular momentum term
arising from that rotation.
And that's equal to
I2 times the angular
velocity of that rotation,
which is capital omega.
And because the axis
there is the z-axis,
this is pointing in
the k hat direction.
So the total angular
momentum of the gyroscope
is I1 times omega in the r
hat direction plus I2 times
capital omega in
the k hat direction
plus m capital omega d squared
in the k hat direction.
The first term, the
r hat component,
is the only part
that's rotating.
So this is a rotating vector.
The k hat terms are constant.
This is the exact expression
for the angular momentum
of a gyroscope.
And now we see the gyroscopic
approximation more precisely
is saying that this
rotating term dominates
over the other two terms.
So it's actually that this
term is very large compared
to either of these two
terms, which, as we can see,
is roughly equivalent to saying
that little omega is very
large compared to big omega.